jetzt kommt auf sie an aussenministerin
annalena baerbock ihre erste richtig
heikle mission heute rein ins
krisengebiet in die ukraine und dann
anschließend nach russland dort trifft
berbalk dann nachher auf einen ganz
wichtigen mann den wir ihnen gleich
zeigen sergei lavrov er ist die eiskalte
rechte hand hier ist er von putin und
der wird genannt mister netz und diesem
mann muss bamberg heute gegenüber sitzen
in die augen schauen ja sie muss gegen
ihn unsere interessen vertreten und das
inmitten kriegsangst in der ukraine
da zittern die menschen vor putin der
seine armee an den grenzen längst hat
aufmarschieren lassen
sie robben durch den sand schmeißen sich
in die büsche hören auf kommandos
ein russischer angriff auf die ukraine
wird immer wahrscheinlicher
das säbelrasseln ist inzwischen so laut
dass sich sogar zivilisten auf putins
mögliche invasion vorbereiten wie ernst
die lage
das sind keine soldaten sondern
zivilisten die hier trainieren aus
großer angst und sorge dass putins
truppen auch in kiew einfallen könnten
und hier ihre familien bedrohen deswegen
trainieren sie den ernstfall deswegen
trainieren sie hier jedes wochenende wie
sie sich dann gegen russische truppen
verteidigen können marc terjung skiff
ist eine solche zivilisten im normalen
leben ist die 45-jährige angestellte bei
einem großkonzern forscht in klinischen
studien seit mehreren monaten kommt sie
samstags hierher
es war eine weitere eskalation an der
grenze also bringt putin die truppen an
die ukrainische grenze und ich habe ein
artikel über territorialverteidigung
gesehen ich habe vorher nichts davon
gewusst aber als ich den artikel sah
entschied ich mich dafür sie alle haben
angst dass russlands präsident wladimir
putin ernst machen könnte und auch die
ukrainische hauptstadt kiew angreift
wir haben alle etwas was uns wertvoll
ist es ist unser land es sind unsere
gräber sind die familien unserer
familien wir wissen ja auch dass die
kommunikation zwischen putin und beiden
nicht sehr erfolgreich war und putin das
risiko einer eskalation immer hoch hält
mehr als 100 tausend russische soldaten
stehen an der grenze bereit für den
einmarsch in die ukraine kampflos wollen
sich die bürger dort nicht ergeben
jansons zugeschaltet in der ukraine ist
jetzt bild vize paul ronzheimer der uns
auch diesen bericht geschickt hat von
marta die sich aufmacht als zivilisten
sich vorbereitet für den krieg paulus
uns jetzt zugeschaltet hallo paul
berichten uns von den menschen in der
ukraine berichtet uns davon wie groß die
angst vor einem krieg dort ist man
schließt ja das was wir dort in diesen
beitrag gesehen haben hat sich hier ein
kind geeignet
und da wo ich mit den menschen sprechen
konnte und es tatsächlich diese stimmung
zivilisten sind bereit sich gegen putin
zu stellen sind bereit irland zu
verteidigen und das ist die große
veränderung die ich auch hier spüre ich
stehe ja mei dann wovor ja ach ja die
menschen erschossen wurden wo die
menschen für freiheit auf die straße
gegangen sind janukowitsch dann gestürzt
wurde und dann ist der krieg entstand
daraus zu können das darf man ja nicht
vergessen der geht schon seit acht
jahren und jetzt diese forderung von
putin die niemand erfüllen kann auf der
welt und die menschen haben tatsächlich
angst das ist die stimmung her wir
spüren was du als reporter dort ab mai
dann für ein besonderes verhältnis zu
den menschen dort hast nun kommt dort
heute unsere neue außenministerin hin
annalena baerbock was erwarten die
menschen dort was erwartet martha dort
von der deutschen außenministerin in
dieser krise was erwartet die ukraine
die ukraine erwartet dass sich
deutschland hinter dieses land stellt da
ist deutschland aufhört mit putin zu
kuscheln dass deutschland aufhört nicht
zu verstehen was hier vorgeht viele sind
enttäuscht über die debatten um nordost
über die gaspipeline dass da nichts
passiert es bei uns stellvertretend nur
ein bisschen für das was die menschen
empfinden ist mit den klitschkos der
bürgermeister möglicherweise
präsidentschaftskandidaten in zwei
jahren hier in der ukraine und mit ihm
habe ich kurz vorher sprechen können
wir sitzen in der ukraine eine große
hoffnung auf den besuch von
außenministerin annalena bomberg weil
sie mit der ablehnung von motto zudem
zwei gezeigt hat dass sie auf die
einzige richtige seite stehen es muss
alles getan werden
dass es nicht zum eine russische
invasion kommt das war eine absolute
albtraum wie hindurch reine brauchen
unterstützung wir brauchen diese waffen
um gerade sonst drohungen gegen russland
oder fall eines angriffs
also paul wehrhahn vitali klitschko sagt
ganz klar sie steht auf der richtigen
seite die hoffnung in annalena baerbock
die ist groß sehen dass die menschen in
der ukraine auch so ist sie dort beliebt
setzen die menschen wirklich auf sie
oder sind sie mittlerweile einem punkt
angekommen dass sie sagen können wir
überhaupt uns noch verlassen können wir
überhaupt noch vertrauen wie ist die
stimmung
das ist die große frage tatsächlich
patricia die sich die menschen stellen
damals als ich fragte hier auf die zwei
hinter mir da standen die menschen in
europa schlagen wir standen für unsere
werte dort für die eu sie haben ihr und
demokratisch sein wir wollen nicht zu
putins reich gehören und das was danach
passiert ist das hat sich schon ein
bisschen enttäuscht die hoffnung was
annalena baerbock angeht die gibt es und
sie wird in wenigen stunden hier hinter
mir auf diesem platz an kanten dagegen
dort jetzt sie erinnern an die
menschenmenge geschossen wurden bei den
protesten für die freiheit 2014 danke
paul in die ukraine danke nach 44 alle
warten gespannt auf diese heikle mission
heute von annalena baerbock die weiter
nach moskau reisen wird heute das alles
erleben sie bei bild live ermittelt dann
hier das statement von annalena baerbock
also der erste auftritt von ihr mitten
in dieser krise inmitten von krieg sagen
ist darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen
mit dem chef der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz
wolfgang ischinger denn es ist eine
schwierige reise die annalena baerbock
heute vor sich hat kriegsangst gibt es
eine reale kriegsgefahr in der ukraine
scherzinger dass sie bei uns sind wie
real ist für sie wie schätzen sie die
situation ein die kriegsgefahr und wie
schwierig ist heute dieser tag für
annalena baerbock
also zum ersten teil ihrer frage die
kriegsgefahr ist sicherlich real
es gibt unendlich viele informationen
darüber wie die ansammlung russische
einheiten in den letzten wochen längeren
wochen sich weiter eskaliert hat es ist
kaum vorstellbar dass nach einer so
langen zeit des throns durch die
russische führung
sozusagen man plötzlich umdrehte und
nach hause fährt und damit dann
zumindest nach russischer auffassung
auch das gesicht verlieren würde also
die gefahr ist real
die frage ist berechtigt was kann jetzt
diplomatisch getan werden ich würde dazu
raten der erwartungen an diese erste
reise unserer neuen außenministerin aber
in das krisengebiet und b nach moskau
jetzt nicht mit allzu hohen erwartungen
zu überfrachten
es ist gut aus meiner sicht dass sie
zuerst in die ukraine fährt und dann
nach moskau weiter fährt es wäre schlimm
gewesen für die ukrainischen nachbarn
und partner wenn sie die reise umgekehrt
angetreten ist also das schon mal
richtig entschieden sagt wolfgang
ischinger wir haben gerade in der
bericht von paul ronzheimer die menschen
gesehen die sich dort vorbereiten auf
den kriegsfall tatsächlich zivilisten
zivilistinnen wie diese mater die uns
paul leben vorgestellt hat die plötzlich
an der waffe trainieren dort im schnee
in der ukraine
was glauben sie können wir im westen
deren erwartungen erfüllen können die
sich tatsächlich auf uns auf uns alle im
westen auf uns deutsche verlassen dass
wir im ernstfall an ihrer seite an der
seite der ukraine stehen
also das was diese
ukrainischen milizen diese zivilisten
hier vor exerzieren ist natürlich
eigentlich
ein tropfen auf einen heißen stein auf
der anderen seite stehen riesige
panzerverbände und ballistische waffen
und enorme bezahlen von flugzeugen aber
es ist trotzdem der versuch
der ukrainische zivilbevölkerung
an dem thema der ab der abschreckung
mitzuwirken und das ist der punkt der
für die bundesrepublik deutschland der
für die eu der für die ganze nato der
allein entscheidende ist wir müssen
alles tun um krieg zu verhüten in dieser
lage und das geht nicht nur durch
freundliche diplomatische worte sage ich
jetzt als als alter hase der diplomatie
soll das geht in diesem fall durch das
klassische nato konzept erstes
abschreckung auch durch militärische
stärke und zweitens umfassendes
dialogangebot und ich denke die
bundesrepublik deutschland muss sich
gemeinsam mit den partnern fragen ob es
hilft
wenn wir über mögliche waffenlieferungen
immer nur mit einem tabu reagieren wenn
wir über massive sanktions überlegungen
gegen russland im falle einer invasion
auch ablehnend reagieren wie das gerade
vor weniger schön friedrich merz gemacht
hat ja was ist denn dann unser beitrag
zur abschreckung wir müssen doch in den
russischen köpfen das gefühl stärken
dass der preis dazu bezahlen wäre im
falle einer militäraktion gegen die
ukraine so hoch ist dass sich dass
möglicherweise doch nicht rechnet und
deswegen ist es gut wenn wir in dieser
lage nichts ausschließen weder massive
wirtschaftliche sanktionen noch
waffenlieferungen natürlich nicht
deutschlands als deutschland sondern
lieferung von defensivwaffen
beispielsweise durch die europäische
union die in dieser lage leider bisher
ja nur am spielfeldrand gestanden ist
und hilflos zuschauen musste ich muss
ihnen sagen ich fühle mich so ein
kleines bisschen erinnert an die erste
hälfte der neunziger jahre als wir
händeringend vor dem jugoslawien krieg
entstanden da mussten 300.000 menschen
sterben bis dann schließlich die usa
heim griffen uns aus der patsche helfen
so ähnlich kommt mir das jetzt vor
jetzt haben wir gerade eingeblendet
gesehen dass wir auf diesen termin von
annalena baerbock natürlich ganz genau
schauen heute mittag zunächst in der
ukraine dann anschließend am abend in
moskau sie haben gerade schon die
erwartungen etwas gedämpft an diesen
antrittsbesuch von der neuen deutschen
außenministerin sie hat diese aufgabe
dem sergej lawrow heute in die augen zu
schauen und sage ich jetzt einmal ganz
undiplomatisch aber das ist ja
tatsächlich eine besondere begegnung
dieser außenminister recke putins rechte
hand wären gerade gesagt diese eiskalte
mann den sie ja bestens kennen von der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz wie macht
man das wie begegnet man diesem sergej
lawrow
also ich kenne es ja die labor seit
mitte der 90er jahre damals war er noch
russischer botschafter bei den vereinten
nationen und man muss zunächst einmal
sagen und das weiß natürlich annalena
baerbock auch ganz genau dass dieser
mann der mit großem abstand
erfahrenste schlaueste
und klügste außenminister ist den ich
persönlich in den letzten 20 30 jahren
kennengelernt habe das ist also schon
eine gewisse größe man mag ihn zyniker
bezeichnen man mag darüber diskutieren
dass das russische außenministerium nur
noch eine hilfs agentur des kreml ist
und keine eigentliche gestaltende rolle
haben kann aber das muss man ernst
nehmen ich glaube wenn ich jetzt frau
werbung begleiten würde würde ich sagen
hören sie ihn erst mal ruhig zu lassen
ihn mal ausreden hört sich das alles an
was er zu sagen hat und ich bin ganz
sicher dass da ein
vernünftiges vielleicht strittiges
streitbares gespräch heraus kommt aber
ich bin der meinung deswegen ist das
wichtig dass er sie kennen lernt dass er
weiß dass sie mit klaren positionen
in moskau ankommt und dass sich hieraus
vielleicht doch erste ansätze zu einer
weiterführenden
deutsch-russischen europäisch russischen
dialog entwickeln wie gesagt mit dem
ziel der kriegs verhütung durch eine
doppelstrategie
abschreckung und kooperationsangebote
danke hört man das danke herzlich für
das gespräch herr singer danke an den
chef der münchner sicherheitskonferenz
für die einblicke in die diplomatie und
in die einblicke in ja den kopf von
sergej lawrow vielen dank